mais le porte à porte c'est un petit
classique électorale et jean vit dans le
quartier depuis 17 ans christine paraît
se présente pour la première fois sous
la bannière néo-démocrate dans la
circonscription de papineau le comté de
justin trudeau
donc vous pensez réellement que vous
pouvez les batteries je peux le battre
sinon je n'allais pas me présenter je lé
candidat pour le parti vert du canada
juan vasquez aussi tentent de déloger le
premier ministre tout comme sa rivale
conservatrice se fit veilleux trop
occupé à faire campagne pour nous
accorder une entrevue et il y a aussi le
candidat du bloc
êtes vous un candidat poteau moi je suis
un militant depuis fort longtemps
militant mais pas poteau dit il reste
que déloger un premier ministre sortant
c'est exceptionnel c'est absolument
possible mais c'est extrêmement rare
nous avons vu des précédents québec mais
au fédéral c'est beaucoup plus rare
surtout que la circonscription de
papineau et considérer le château fort
de justin trudeau depuis son élection en
elle inclut parc extension le deuxième
quartier le plus pauvre pays où on
trouve une forte population immigrante
mais avec l'arrivée du nouveau campus de
l'université de montréal
l'embourgeoisement et la fièvre
spéculative c'est l'accès au logement
qui est devenue l'enjeu dominant et
c'est là dessus que les candidats font
campagne
je m'inquiète pour les gens qui perdent
leur logement est une femme savent même
pas où aller
apparemment avoir été des électeurs du
premier ministre du canada n'a d'aucune
façon régler les problèmes de logement
ici de pouvoir aider vos jambes et on
peut les loyers puis de construire
justement de logement social malgré tous
les efforts sur le terrain
la popularité de justin trudeau demeure
forte à votre photo de zouzou demain
mais on le voit deux fois par année pour
la fête de l'indépendance grecque et la
fête de l'indépendance de l'inde
c'est tout bref comme les premiers
ministres qui l'ont précédé le candidat
justin trudeau n'a pas à s'inquiéter
je vous dirais que je trudeau peut
dormir très confortable magot à propos
de papineau ici jacques andré
charbonneau radio canada montréal